She said to me once,
I wish he would just kill yourself.
You're such a burden to me.
He said,
I think I was nine when my mom drove me
down to the deepest part of Baja
California and she walks me up to an
orphanage and she knocks on the door and
the guy comes to the door and she says,
I found this kid,
and she left me there for 90 days until
my grandmother could get out of her
where she had dumped me and my
grandmother came and rescued me.
My mom beat me every single day of my
elementary school years with things you
could imagine in a lot of things you
couldn't.
Every day my back was bloodied and
scarred.
In fact,
I had to wear three tee shirts to school
each day,
first tee shirt,
because the blood would seep through
second tee shirt.
You could still see it.
Finally,
the third tee shirt,
you couldn't see any blood kids at
school.
They'd make fun of me a fool.
It's 100 degrees.
Why are you wearing three tee shirts?
And then he stopped speaking so
overwhelmed with emotion,
and he seemed to be staring at a piece
of his story that only he could see
whether he could regain his speech.
She said through his tears,
I wore three tee shirts well into my
adult years because I was ashamed of my
wounds.
I didn't want anybody to see him.
But now I welcome by roads.
I run my fingers over my scars.
My woes are my friends.
After all,
how can I help heal the wounded if I
don't welcome my own wounds in awe,
came upon everyone.
The measure of our compassion lies not
in our service of those on the margins,
but only in our willingness to see
ourselves in kinship with them.
And indeed you have to brace yourselves
because people will accuse you of
wasting your time and you stand with the
poor and the powerless and the
voiceless.
You stand with those whose dignity has
been denied and you stand with those
whose burdens are more than they can
bear.
And you will go from here and have this
exquisite privilege once in a while,
to be able to stand with the easily
despised and the readily left out
with the demonized so that the
demonizing will stop a gentle,
kind soul.
He's proof that only the soul that
ventilator to the world with tenderness
has any chance of changing the world.